last season on Conan hello you want me
to move the Tonight Show to 12:05 forget
it I'm not doing it go to hell
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the good news is you'll live the bad
news is we'll never work in network
television again you have got to get a
job
we have 14 kids do something for this
family conan job I don't know how so as
I think you can see I believe I'd make a
marvelous addition to your team you have
absolutely no advertising experience
plus it's 1965 and then two years old
thank you you're very good-looking we
had amazing musical guest we had Pearl
Jam I don't care who you were I just
asked her some extra sweet and sour
sauce it's like I put seven Forks not
sweet first they said Obama's is so hard
then they say he's Muslim now they're
saying he wasn't even born in this
country has got me thinking okay the guy
might not be qualified to be president
but I guess he is qualified to drive a
cab in New York City
please go supposed to be third and call
the place I want you to move The Tonight
Show at 12:05 I don't care work get a
job I'll call the police
you're very good-looking
[Music]
don't do it Conan Larry King under
Guardian a but you're not dead never
mind that the words foyer
basic cable basic Conan I think you'll
find our Terms very attractive I think
you have to be
[Music]
well looks like everything's gonna be
okay oh come on
[Music]
[Applause]
the season premiere of code
[Applause]
you